downing streets parties have achieved
what politicians call cut through
it's politics the turnstile operator at
ghoul football club wants to talk about
what do you think boris johnson should
do he's out here
yeah definitely yeah
i mean i just think he's
you know from even before he got in he's
always his track record shows he can't
be adjusted
both home and away supporters here have
conservative mps and there are some
strong views about the wave of
allegations against the prime minister
and his staff
dan holland has traveled across from
grimsby
a red wall tory who says he's had enough
it's telling people i can't see the
loved ones and things like that and then
flaunting it if you like that he's
probably just one step too far and they
cover up some of the lies i don't think
he can hide behind it anymore really
the pressure on boris johnson has
increased since he had to publicly
apologize to the queen for parties that
took place on the night before the duke
of edinburgh's funeral five of his mps
have now called for him to step down
i think we're up to 17 incidents now i'm
pretty sure that's not the end of it
um and it
these revelations are interfering
preventing the prime minister from
functioning
in his role it's actually stopping the
government from functioning
and that's untenable
and at a speech in london the labour
leader himself pictured with a drink at
a meeting during lockdown last year said
the prime minister should resign for the
sake of the country
he's got to go
um
and of course there's a party advantage
in him going but actually it's now in
the national interest that he goes so
it's very important now that
the tory party does what it needs to do
and gets rid of him
in ghoul town center the conservative mp
did not go so far but he did tell me
he's very annoyed getting drunk in the
basement i know the prime minister
wasn't there of number 10 the night
before the duke of edinburgh's funeral
clearly you should have known that
that's not acceptable behavior um so i'm
frustrated i'm irritated as i think a
lot of my constituents are as well
once that irritation becomes a topic of
discussion at football grounds it
focuses minds both inside and outside
number 10.
gerard's sky news ghoul